Let's look at another attack called the DNS
amplification attack. This attack exploits the asymmetry in
size between DNS queries and their responses. So
an attacker might send a DNS query for a
particular domain, and that query might only be
60 bytes. In sending the query, however, the
attacker might indicate that the source. For this
query is some victim IP address. Thus the resolver
might send a reply which is nearly two
orders of magnitude larger to a victim. So the
name of the attack amplification comes from the
fact that the query is only 60 bytes and
a reply is considerably larger. So, by simply
generating a small amount of initial traffic, the attacker
can cause the DNS resolver. To generate a
significantly larger amount of attack traffic. If we start
adding other attackers, all of which specify
the victim as the source, then all of
these giant replies start heading towards the victim,
and we have a denial of service attack
on the victim. Two possible defenses against
this attack are to prevent IP address spoofing
in the first place using, for example, the
appropriate filtering rule or to disable the ability
for a DNS resolver to resolve queries from arbitrary locations on the Internet.